for those of you who sat through
avengers endgame and expected to
post-credit scenes you will be really
pleased to hear that spider-man far from
home does actually have two of them now
these set up for further Marvel
Cinematic Universe characters as well as
giving a nod back to Captain Marvel
we're gonna take a look at both of them
and yes spoilers are ahead in the first
post-credit scene Peter as spider-man
and MJ are now dating she knows his
identity but it is still a wider secret
the pair swing into New York West 33rd
Street and 8th Avenue a breaking news
sting hits a screen above New York Penn
Station Mysterio played by Jake
Gyllenhaal was killed in the final
battle but is seen giving a manipulated
pre-recorded message that a drone strike
on Tower Bridge with spider-man's fault
and that Peter Parker is spider-man the
screen then cuts to jay jonah Jameson
and the Daily Bugle repeating this
expose a fans of the Sam Raimi respired
Man franchise will be pleased that JK
Simmons returns as Jay jonah Jameson he
also appeared as a character in Avengers
Assemble ultimate spider-man and other
titles so the most vital thing that we
can take away from this expose a is that
either for future Spidey installments
Peter won't be living his double life or
they'll have to explain this incident
away as a lie it also showcases the
power of the media to manipulate the
superhero image in a post endgame MCU
it's also rather prescient in the era of
fake news after all
Mysterio's final lines on Tower Bridge
were people just need to believe and
nowadays they will believe anything we
previously sat through the whole Spidey
is bad guy scenario in the Sam Raimi
trilogy so it's a franchise really going
to set this up again
in the second post-credit scene Nick
Fury and agent Maria Hill are seen
driving down a city street talking about
how Quentin Mysterio fooled them then in
a huge twist Fury transforms back into
the skull Talos ben mendelsohn as
talents have been impersonating fury
throughout the whole entire movie fans
will remember him as one of the initial
antagonists in Captain Marvel who had
been impersonating Fury early in the
film then was revealed to be a good guy
Sauron who had been impersonating he'll
tell tell us that they need to call Nick
Fury to update him on what's happened
Talos calls the real Nick Fury we
initially believed him to be on a
tropical island barefoot drinking out
the coconut and wearing a tropical shirt
but the island scene is a hologram and
theory is actually on a large scroll
ship traveling through space he's
relaxing and doesn't seem to be in any
present danger so the first question
when did Talos become fury on earth did
fury come back immediately after the
snap then have something important to
attend to so send Talos to impersonate
him if in the movie Talos remembers Tony
Stark's funeral then it is possible that
the real Nick Fury didn't actually
attend perhaps he is so relaxed on the
ship though because they're waiting for
something to happen or making a very
long journey we know Captain Marvel is
missing from chunks of Avengers endgame
because she was off helping other
planets affected by the snap if fury
assisting with this or on his own quest
looking back up Fury's loins in the film
the audience is dropped a few small
clues that he was a scroll or lon when
asked for the Captain Marvel is
available to help fight the elementals
fury says don't invoke her name which
seems like a bit of an overreaction also
at the end of the movie he tells happy
Hogan that appearances can be deceiving
furies appearance on the scroll ship is
a potential set up for the next MCU
installments we already know that the
Scrolls of the movies divert from their
character Alka the comics they appear as
antagonist to the fantastic fall in 1962
Fantastic Four number two and then
fighting the crease Gulf War in Avengers
and then take over human form on earth
in 2008 Secret Invasion and at the end
of Captain Marvel they're portrayed as
peaceful refugees that are allied to
Captain Marvel and follow her through
the universe we've also had a brief
crossover in two Guardians before in
2014's guardians of a galaxy
during Stan Lee's cameo rocket is
scanning members of the public from a
long range the equipment shows scroll
writing up on the screen so the
characters from guardians might have
some familiarity with the scrolls before
Disney has a untitled Marvel movie
slated through 2022 so it's possible
that Fury's journey will overlap the
next logical fit for fury in the scrolls
offworld might be the reportedly cosmic
setting of guardians of the galaxy 300
Captain Marvel - there's also the
Eternals in development as well as a
reported Fantastic Four reboot as early
as 2022 considering the scrolls were
first featured in the Fantastic Four
comics this would be a great way to tie
together two elements of the MCU what
did you think of the two post credits
each comment below
you